[Music]
so this woman
she thought that she was actually going
to be getting a hitman
from this website called rent a hitman
that is so stupid
but instead she got arrested for
attempted murder
good dumbass because it's actually
strippers or something that come
no it's a fake site cops probably set it
up it's a fake
site and the site's owner said that they
have helped
prevent more than and 130 murders oh my
god what
how many stupid people live in this
country there's a lot of stupid people
rentahitman.com
yes that's how few stupid people live in
this country
only 130. pretty good pretty good
numbers for 100 million yeah out of 300
million that is pretty good pretty good
that's pretty
i like to know the thought process well
i gotta have someone to murder my
husband
where do i find one oh okay hitman.com
what a convenient place thank god
someone thought of the service already
yeah they bought the google ads so it's
the first thing that pops up to
like well hold on i'm a little smarter
than that though i want to go on yelp
yep good reviews really good reviews
i absolutely got a satisfied customer
one star but hitler was late
i know i can actually read some of these
like testimonials oh
all right so this chick wendy or this
lady i paid for one person they murdered
the whole family what a deal
that got uh arrested for for trying to
murder her ex-husband it's an alcatraz
uniform
the stripes who still have stripes in
michigan
oh i don't know they got it from a movie
costume website jesus
but yes she actually filled out the
service request
request form and so as soon as the
site's owner
received this form they contacted the
authorities and then the police
they went in like posing as a hitman and
she offered five thousand dollars to
she looks like she hasn't slept in years
though
how are you gonna have bags on top of
your eyelid but then she has bed head
like she's been sleeping for a long time
yeah so this is these are screenshots of
the website
oh my god hitman your point and click
solution
and then what does it say here it says
100 hipaa compliant
with the hitman information privacy and
protection of 1964.
are they union well that's what it
sounds like what the [ __ ] is that photo
supposed to show you
why i even have a photo yeah it's just
it's probably a stock photo
maybe it's showing no evidence it's left
the website like oh build it
like the big cart here here's another
one it says
body problem that needs resolving with
over 17
985 us-based field-operated operators
we can find a solution that's right for
you
your privacy is important to us i wish
they had a counter for all the like
successful
kills that they've had and it just like
keeps going higher that's good
that'll be so good yeah here's here are
the testimonials so customer
testimonials that's awesome so it says
uh phil m from florida said guido
pictures
guido and his public relations crew were
able to resolve
a five-year dispute in a matter of days
highly recommend
lara s from arizona said caught my
husband cheating with the babysitter and
resolved after a free public relations
consultation
i'm single again and looking to mingle
thanks guido
and then fernando m from kansas says my
schedule is too busy to get my hands
dirty so i consulted with r8ah
and they handled my public relations
issue for me
gracias r-a-h how
fun to build the site yeah i'm sure they
did it as jokes
for sure they even have this like banner
it says we are still
open during the cover 19 pandemic
socially distance
yeah they said that there are field
operatives and coveted
19 training that they have undergone
stringent cov19 training and are in full
compliance with all social distancing
recommendations from the cdc
our snipers maintain at least 350 feet
contactless we only employ snipers
no they even have at the end for the
duration of the covet 19 pandemic our
wuhan
offices will be working on a reduced
schedule
that's tight they're awesome if you're
kind of like if you live in a bubble i
can see how you would fall for this
because it seems like they
like it's like a legit site well i mean
people fall for like
you know tv evangelists like every
single day
yeah but they're the real ones though
true true i'm talking about the fake
ones oh oh oh
the ones that fit but when you get the
holy water that's just
that's real yeah or if you send three
dollars to get a green bookmark that's
way different than all the other
bookmarks that's real
yeah yeah yeah or the publishing house
whatever the sweepstakes thing that
people keep
like believing i got fooled when i was
in third grade i got a
a letter and it said that it was it was
for my grandma
and it says you have already won 25
000 you must collect i was like grandma
this [ __ ]
it's gonna get us out of the poor house
you need to sign up for this [ __ ] right
now
i was in like third grade yeah i was
like that too i'm like mom we could win
money we could really win money you
should mail it in
you want to hear something stupid um so
bart and i were in harvard i thought
he don't like sharing stuff but we're in
our late 20s and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wait what we got we didn't get fooled
so they said this [ __ ] like what was
it like uh it looked like this legit
uh what was it like a counter or like a
like a tracking device or what the [ __ ]
was it but
i don't know it looked like they spent
money on it you know what i mean so we
were like
this must be legit because they're not
sending this to thousands of people
so then uh so we got this tractor
so it's like it was like uh there's like
this um almost like uh
you know you know when you live in an
apartment complex and they have like the
the key fob thing that lets you get
like into doors oh yeah yeah it's like
this fog why do i remember this it was
like a fob thing that comes in this
package and it's like you could win
this free toyota it said could or
something like that or says you already
have but you just have to come in and
like spin the wheels
so so obviously it's so dumb but we're
like
we're like we didn't know what to do
what if this is we actually win so we
actually drove down
to the toyota dealership and we go in
there and they're like
so we're here to collect our free car
and then they're like all right
building the dealership you have to walk
in a bungalow where like it's all creaky
and stuff and walk in
20 other families and [ __ ] everyone ever
wants to keep up
and then they're like all right so what
you have to do is spin this wheel first
like 28 or something yeah but were the
other families older than you
yeah i don't know why i think when i saw
that i was so ashamed of how [ __ ]
dumb i was that i'm like i don't even
want to i think 99 percent we already
didn't believe it but we just wanted to
see if the one person was like nah
i was about 50 50. i was in there dude i
feel you
uh we went there we spun the whole thing
you spun it yeah we spun
it we waited no it was like some [ __ ]
bull come back tomorrow to collect
whatever and we'll have
one of our socials what do they get from
it our contact information yeah yeah and
they bring people
in and then they sell a car to them at
the end yeah so
it was at the toyota dealership yeah so
you go in and you go i want to turn it i
go well you didn't but i'll give you a
good deal it's almost like winning
while you're excited we can give you a
deal on one of these actually
you didn't win but you did win a
discount i know right we fell for it
uh what we say oh in my young 20s i was
actually
i was 19 i wasn't even 20 yet but damn
it makes your story already better
kind i don't know no it's worse it was a
it was a thing from western union and it
said like i won
some like you know lottery thing even
though
i don't remember ever buying a ticket
for a lottery or
like submitting myself but i'm like well
let's check it out
and so they had given me a check for
three thousand dollars
and they're like okay you just need to
deposit this into your bank account and
then mail us that amount of money
to release these funds so i'm like well
they're already paying for it
so like whatever but then i also like my
skeptical mind was in there and i'm like
you know what i'm gonna call western
union like individually like i'm gonna
go to the website like find the legit
western union
make sure that the money is in there
yeah and so i do that
and the the western union is like yeah
like there's fifty thousand dollars
in this account and they said that uh
basically you just have to release it
um and so whatever the instructions tell
you to do like you should do it they
said that on western union what did you
call the number that was on
no i went independently but i think
that's like they probably
knew how the system worked so they set
it up a certain way yeah
but yeah they're like yes account says
it has 50 000
in it so you know it is just waiting to
be collected so i was like [ __ ]
maybe i did enter a lottery so i go to
the bank
and i deposit this 3 000 check but
there's you know that part of you that's
like yeah
something feels wrong here like this is
too good to be true so it probably is
so but i went and deposited it and then
my mom's a banker right
and so i tell her about it and she's
like you need to go to the bank right
now
and tell them that was a fraudulent
check and blah blah blah so i go there
and i'm [ __ ] crying and i'm
like i think i did something illegal i
didn't mean to
i didn't i like was so scared that i was
gonna be like put in jail or something
and i was like i think i deposited a
fraudulent check but like look
i didn't mean to and like i didn't know
i didn't know it was reverse
reversal and they were like it's okay
okay it was from here okay
yeah yeah yeah this is a fraudulent
check but like we understand they were
like really understanding
i was like god this is so scary that was
a popular scam though because that
happened to me too but i was looking for
a roommate yeah
and people and people were hitting me up
and this one guy
was like oh that key thing i can't no no
he's like i can't move in
until next month but i can give you a
deposit right now
uh and so here here's the check
so he sent me a check and he's like just
go put in the bank and then can you
western union me the money and i was
like
no [ __ ] you like but i but i did
i did almost put the check in the bank
because i it just seemed he was like
talking to me normally he seemed
completely blessed
there's a lot of craigslist scams that
were like um we're not here
we live in we moved to london but this
apartment's available we just need
tenants right away
um you can come pick the key up just
leave the deposit here and like you can
come
pick the key up and they have pictures
of the apartment but then
there's no like real contact info yeah i
was i was talking to one of those like
they were trying to duke me for one of
those two and i i remember responding
back like
do you think i'm this stupid and then he
never responded it would all be they
should have said yeah
it'd be something ridiculous like it's
like it's worked a lot like i did
it's like eight hundred dollars not only
four bedroom in on the beach you know
and it's like wow what a deal yeah i
know
i don't know i don't i want to be
scammed but i don't you know
you want to be scared yeah i do just to
have a story
uh just the experience you know and then
i'm just like oh you got me you son of a
[ __ ]
well not like this lady though right
what happened to this lady she was like
yeah he's like what happened to this
lady there's a lady
remember she rented a hitman oh the
infomercial jokes were funny though
when we were talking about yeah yeah
that was cool oh good you didn't
remember part
it's like proof he remembered part
yeah the the website's owner so that
they have been setting or that they set
this website up back in 2005.
so since then they've been catching all
these people thinking they're running
they're so stupid yeah 130 murders
prevented [ __ ] i want to set one up now
a hitman thing yeah something fake oh i
thought you meant you wanted to submit a
form i'm like
geo are you like joe you just need the
story
i have plenty wayfair cabinets.com no
and then we cash through his
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out oh i
like that okay i'm down i'm down
rentakid.com
somebody shows up you got a [ __ ] lead
pipe and like i just wanted expensive
furniture
like [ __ ] no no we're going to do the
rent a kid yeah that's why it's got to
be
like buried yeah on the nose like this
like these people
definitely want to rent a kid and then
we [ __ ] torture those people
absolutely
discreet you can ran a kid and then
people show up
to take the kid and then i go have you
ever seen a snake
bite your nuts i like it let's do it
[Music]